why do I think Trump will serve no
prison time this is just an opinion
people can disagree with this okay
if you
think that at the tail end of a year or
more of delays
Trump won't take a plea he says he won't
that this will go to trial
that Trump will be found guilty and that
he will be sentenced at what then might
be 77 or 78 or 79 years old depending on
how long this all takes if you think
he's going to be sentenced to prison
then
I think all of that is unlikely but even
if he were I believe that he will be
allowed to serve whatever sentence there
is in home confinement now a couple
people wrote in and said no there are
special facilities for people you know
known like Trump or what
it's just my opinion guys I don't think
Trump will do a single day
as far as this case is concerned